I can really hug my real hug that's as
much open hardness as I can take it was
open you felt it open up a deep feeling
right yeah I can do that I just I just
choose to do it occasionally not all the
time
unlike the Kinkos have open heart yeah
you you are so up and hearted you
exhaust other people let's say the only
guy know where you go like this and I'm
like I'm tired
he just drained me with his compassion
yeah I'm giving you too much credit
neediness because I need I need you
you're a good friend and I need you to
bring me back to earth when does this
friendship happen I I uh I I don't hear
from you the last time I saw you you
were frightened and panicky at a party
yeah and you came up to me I'm like I
don't know it's if it's working out and
what did you do you reeled me back in
that was before we started doing this
show that's right and I said look you
know it's gonna you you are who you are
just show up for work have faith in
yourself
you've worked hard for this don't freak
yourself out and you're terrible very
nice to you because we were in an
awkward situation you mean the party yes
it was an awkward party it wasn't yes we
were both at Dane Cook's house and we
couldn't figure out why
it's where he's like he asked us to go
like I guess we're going here we gonna
go yeah you want to see his house yeah
his house was so clean I had moments
where I'm like he doesn't have anything
here like this is a prop house why do I
like he must have lived somewhere else
and he just does this for parties yeah
people come over very clean I actually
asked him about it he had rugs removed
like really like people who are well-off
have these rugs that you can't put your
feet on I don't mean to out gain he's
got he's got rug money it's work cuz I
just bought a rug seriously yeah
you know I I I have space in my house
now I know I don't I didn't add anything
on it just you know you know my
girlfriend's gone so what you feel like
with a rug you feel like I've changed
things everything's different so I got
this rug yeah that like it's a shag rug
they say like an Ikea rug but I think
about the only expensive rug at IKEA the
only one that I saw that I liked I'm
like what does this cost $200 $800 rug
really you're gonna grown at $800 what
is it's The Price is Right
oh my god 800
[Music]
ain't no one definitely an amazing rod
[Music]